why not pitch netflix and get them to do
an upcoming project
i doubt i would ever get in the room
with them i mean i'm just being honest i
just i don't know how it i don't know
how i would get in the room with them
um you know i
it's weird in this business too and this
is the honest truth is
you know i'm sure i mean i'm not saying
it was easy for the duffer brothers with
stranger things but it did probably help
that they hadn't done a whole lot
um when they pitched that what happens
in this business is it's sort of a
double-edged sword is you know if you
start to do things
and you have a track record and you made
x number of movies
well okay that's great because it shows
you can do this and you can do it you've
done it more than once and obviously
you've got some kind of you know
track record skills and so on but for
some people
depending on the type of movies you make
in my case it's horror movies
that's a stigma it stigmatizes you and
then most people think
that's all that they can do that's all
that guy knows how to do
um i mean let's just i just throw a name
out there wes craven on a
obviously way bigger level you know he
struggled with that his entire career
that's why he made the movie with meryl
streep because he just wanted to he was
tired of making heart
he wanted to make other things most
horror directors want to make other
types of movies
they just don't get to george romero had
plenty of things he wanted to do was
craven things
they all do john carpenter all of them
but they're generally not going to get
it and i'm talking about major people
here
they're not going to get it because
their track record says
he makes this type of film so my track
record says i make these type of films
and i don't think that netflix would
care about that i think they'd see that
as a negative maybe if i'd only made one
short they might be interested in having
a meeting with me
you know a short that was very hot let's
just say
played you know some major fest but
and that doesn't mean that's not because
i don't have any ideas for things or i
don't have ideas that could be expanded
to
tv series but yeah
so having you know been here in the 90s
and then you know entering a new era
where there's there's going to be
younger people
in charge do you find they have a harder
time telling you no
than maybe gen xers or people
in in in another decade where it seemed
like it was okay to be a little more
blunt
and now we're very sensitive and we're
dancing on everybody's feelings
and nobody wants to tell anybody no but
then they're not telling you the truth
because
i'm seeing a lot of that and sometimes
maybe it's just better people
just tell you no well yeah i think it
yeah there is a there is a
it's it's because of you know so much
online communication you know there's
the classic you know no response you
know sort of the ghosting
or whatever that people do where they
just if they they don't want to
they want to move away from the
situation or say no or whatever they
just won't do anything
i guess like no response is okay
whatever that is you know
i don't know i mean we're
we're pretty straightforward with people
like we're very straightforward in
auditions
we're very straightforward in uh
meetings about like when we're
interviewing uh
crew you know that doesn't mean that
things aren't still gonna come up later
sometimes it doesn't matter how much you
talk to you're blue in the face and
impress
something upon someone they'll always
they they aren't listening to you
or they've got an agenda or they just
decide that they've
you know they've got another idea later
on that can all happen you have to be
prepared for that
we just we just try to be as
straightforward as possible and what
other people do
we can't really say but if we get a bad
vibe off of somebody
or our non-committal vibe or whatever we
just move on
you know i mean i just there's a lot of
moving on you do in this in this
business
too much you know and and sometimes it
happens way quicker than you think it
will
but that's just that's something else
you need to get used to if you're gonna
have a career
i think on any level is is just used to
change and
new faces and you know and kind of
self-starting
you know and coming up with things like
almost like every film is your first
film
you know i'm sure you've heard that
before people say you know i feel like
every time
i've felt that way many times that i'm
trying to pitch something to some people
and i'm going
why do i even have to do this i've got
over 20 features
because because that's just how this
business is people
you know they always want you always got
to prove yourself to somebody in some
way
some more than others but you know
but knowing that doesn't make it less
stressful
knowing that you have to like self-start
again and then you just go okay well i'm
back here it's annoying i mean i'll be
honest with you it's annoying and
of course because you
you know there's other people that don't
have to do that
so there are i mean on a higher tier
there are people who don't have to do
that but there's an alarming number of
accomplished people who do
uh you know so that makes it a little
bit easier to take i guess when you know
that
you know some of your heroes still have
to you know put on a dog and pony show
for
you know investors or whatever um
i don't know i mean we we've tried to
we've tried to to take things
try to be as calm as we can over time
that's one thing we've that josephine
and i both try to sort of learn
with some of these experiences is you
can get very heated over these little
situations sometimes with film
that's something i'd probably tell
anybody really is a lot of times
it's not as big a deal as you think it
is if it's an editing issue
if it's a sound issue if it's a certain
shot you don't
believe me it's not as big a deal as you
think it is
um you know sometimes you can get very
fixated on these type of things and you
can get very stressed about this stuff
it's not about personality so this is
technical things too
you just try to be as calm as you can
in those type of situations you know
you